many of you may be familiar with linked
lists they're commonly used to hold
lists of items
in the same vein as arrays but how do
you know which one to use and why
i don't mean just some guidelines on
when to use one or the other but
understanding fundamentally the
connection between these data structures
and the underlying memory
what are linked lists in the most simple
terms
they're a way of storing several items
at once typically in code you'll have a
situation like this where you want to
store a bunch of junk
let's pretend we have a linked list
class so const name
equals new linked list and names.add
fry names.add zoidberg names.ad
etc etc where names is a linked list
and i've added four names to the linked
list and now
i'm able to traverse it search for items
that sort of thing instead of having
four separate variables
in other words avoiding this situation
where you have kant's name one equals
fry
constant name two equals zoidberg etc
etc
these just seem like a race with more
steps a little bit
yeah i mean they're both collections of
items but let's talk more about the
underlying memory
if you think about memory as this
gigantic series of slots
each of which holds one byte and this is
all ordered sequentially
there's a few ways of kind of rationing
out memories that emerge
pretty naturally imagine your family is
out to eat at a fancy restaurant
so your party arrives and you ask the
maitre d for a table for four
there's room so you all get seated at a
nice table far away from the bathroom
a little bit later on your friend bob
and his family drops by
so you need some extra seats there's a
few natural options
if the table you're at had some extra
room already by chance
then just sit down no problem if the
table had no extra room
then what can happen is that the major d
can find a bigger table that can
accommodate you all
and then seat you all there together and
finally in this example
they can seat bob and his family at a
new table instead
and just let you know where they are so
you can say hi or whatever
memory isn't that much different you've
got your layout of memory here
and i've already allocated some memory
to source and items
and if i want to store another number
then there's a few common ways i can do
this
if there's some more room in the piece
of memory that i've been assigned i can
write to the end
but if there's no more room i could ask
for a bigger piece copy everything there
and then write my new thing in and
finally i could allocate a new piece of
memory
and then in the new piece i can store
the new data
and an address to the first chunk of
data and this
this is what linked lists are let's draw
some more pictures
in more concrete terms you've got these
fragments of memory
let's call each of these a node and a
node is structured so that it has two
sections
the first section will hold the data you
want to store and the second section
which i'll call
next will hold the address in memory of
the next node in the chain
so let's say i'm storing numbers that
means i can allocate a node which gives
me a chunk of memory
i can write a number into the data part
and leave the next part empty
and then when i want to store a second
number i allocate another node
so let's say i got this little block of
memory now and i write the number into
it
and then in the second part the next
part i write the address of the first
block
forming a chain with this new node as
the head
and it should follow that i can keep
doing this keep allocating new nodes
keep writing more values in there and
the chain just keeps growing organically
so are these better than arrays or worse
or what
to understand that we need to understand
how to do basic operations with them
the first thing we'll talk about is
traversing the list just visiting all of
the elements one by one
arrays are obviously pretty simple loop
over one at a time
incrementing an index but linked lists
are a little different because of their
layout and the fact that they're not
guaranteed to be contiguous in memory
you start at the head node and move to
the next item in the chain
you look at the next pointer i.e the
address of the next node
and you continue following these
pointers over and over until you reach
the one that points nowhere
the code will look something like this
so beginning at the head node we'll have
a loop where we assign cur node equals
curnode.next
and then we terminate the loop if
current node is null meaning we've gone
off the end
and as you can see here's the c plus
version here's the python version
they're all basically the same thing a
simple loop with some checks
it stands to reason then that searching
in a linked list is basically traversing
the list
checking each item in sequence until you
find what you want
but here's where things get a little
interesting let's delete an item from
the list
let's say i want to delete this item in
the middle here what you do is you
perform a little surgery
taking the previous item in the chain
and point the next address to the node
after the one that you've deleted
that's it it's effectively out of the
list now adding a new node anywhere in
the list is the same deal
but backwards to add one you allocate a
new node
change the previous node's next pointer
to point to your new node
and then change your new nodes next to
the next node in the chain
the description might be a little
confusing but the picture should be
pretty simple
now let's compare them to arrays i
really hope you're up to speed on cache
locality otherwise make sure to watch
the first video in the series before we
move on
we can compare arrays and linked lists
along two dimensions
there's performance and there's memory
usage let's walk through some common
operations now
traversing a list although in both cases
you're just going over the elements one
by one
in the case of the linked list each node
could be literally anywhere in memory
and if it could be anywhere in memory
that means that the prefetcher
might not be able to cache it for you
ahead of time so there's a potential for
a cache miss every single element
so although you're technically taking as
many steps i
you're looking at the same number of
items an array is just easier for the
cpu to process
random access this is like give me the
fourth element of the array
super easy with arrays because you just
calculate the address as the base plus
the index and you get that memory
but with linked lists this isn't easy at
all you have to traverse the list
starting at the first node
so this really sucks insertion and
deletion
here's where things get a little
interesting so with insertion
into arrays unless you're putting
something right at the end
and you happen to have some free space
then you're going to have to move around
the contents of the array
deleting is pretty much the same deal a
lot of copying and moving elements
around if you're trying to preserve the
order of the array
with linked lists if you have a quick
way to get to the position you want to
insert or delete at
the insertion or deletion itself is
trivial it costs
almost nothing but the trick is you need
to have a fast way of getting to that
node
so this one under the right
circumstances is way way faster than an
array
but it has to be under the right
circumstances and it should follow that
inserting right at the beginning of a
linked list is super easy
but kind of sucks for an array so a win
for linked lists here
memory wise there's some neat things to
explore here too
unless you allocate more space than you
need arrays pretty much
exactly represent the data without any
extra overhead
but linked lists each of those nodes
means that you have to store the address
of the next node
and so linked lists tend to use a little
bit more memory but an interesting thing
to note is that
let's say that you've got a small fixed
amount of memory
and you've already done a bunch of
allocation in there so i'll just cross
off a bunch of sections as being used
already
now if you were to try to allocate an
array of a few items
you pretty much can't in this situation
but a linked list is really flexible
each node can be allocated in the space
between the used sections
so although technically it uses more
memory there's a flexibility there that
the array just doesn't have
why would i ever choose this over an
array the canned response is to say
you evaluate your needs and if you need
to say do lots of insertions and
deletions go for a linked list
but that's pretty vague i'll buck the
trend a bit and say that not that that
advice is wrong
but i'll add that i've actually had very
few instances in my career where i've
needed a raw linked list
in just about every case i've started
with dynamic arrays and switched over to
a linked list as an optimization
in my spatial hashgrids video i
originally implemented a lot of this as
maps
but switched to arrays of linked lists
as a way to massively speed things up
in actual production code i've done
similar things used
linked lists swap in replacements and
extremely specific circumstances
and i've also used them when trying to
write my own memory allocator for fun
when i was at google i did a whole bunch
of interviews and one of my favorite
questions to give
early on before it was banned involved
writing a hybrid data structure where
the best answer was using a linked list
in conjunction with something else so i
won't say that they're super common
but they're an amazing thing to have up
your sleeve when the time is right
if you've watched up until this point it
must have been useful so consider buying
me a coffee or something on patreon
otherwise like and subscribe as always
really helps me out
until next time cheers